have you ever heard the same before the
early bird gets the worm you ever heard
this okay you got to be all ready to
work because you're they were just too
warm right you know what they forget to
tell you about that story whatever
happened to the late warm you know the
late warm that slept in he's alive the
early worm is dead because the bird
aided that was hurting so it's the part
of the story about this just because
you're Ernie doesn't mean you're the
bird you could be an early warned that
gets eaten up Kaia birth so let me
explain to the difference in a world of
business in business there's the hunter
there's the hunt ed there's the one
that's prepared there's the one that's
not prepared there's the one that yet
not they're being disciplined about
exactly what the competitors doing
there's the worm that's just being
casual thinking if I get up I'm going to
go out and win you kind of have your
edge you can't just feel a warm skin I'm
going to wake up in the morning I'm
gonna go out there and win be prepared
have an edge know the competitor know
the market stay tuned on what's going on
in your industry study the industry
study the marketplace study your people
study human nature so when you're facing
your opponent and you guys are fighting
off for this one customer she is looking
at you she is looking at the opponent
whoever wins is the early bird whoever
doesn't is the one and you don't want to
be the one because you'll be someone
breakfast early in the morning so go out
there be the bird
[Music]
you